第今日はこちらはしている花粉です
今日はですねええ話
どういう風にして自分のその
会話の能力ですね話する能力を改善するかという点について話ししたいんです
私がたくさんこのインプってですね多読多聴
いわゆるたくさん読んだりたくさん聴いたりこれがいたり
その
言語その2
その言葉の勉強においてですねいかに大切であるということに関しては今日はもう何回
も何グラム
そのリリーをつくりましたけれども今日はそのオープン登らんですよ
話する方に対してちょっと意見を伸ばしたいと思います
まず第1点ですね流暢に
話せ話するためにたくさん話ししなければわかるがいい
私は私がいろんな言葉を話せるんですけれども私は一番自由に話せる言葉が私が一番
たくさん話ししたその実際の経験のある言葉なんですよだからたくさん話ししないと
いけない
それがまず一つだけ
もう第2点目ですねその最初の間にですね勉強の初めて
始めてる問いにですねそんなに話しする必要がないと思います
駄文ラグ分のその
間国が主者がですね学校でその
お話お話をさせるんですよ
しかし結果的にですねそれは神奈川の学校でフランス語を習っている生徒でもあれは
日本でも他の国でもそんなに流暢に話せないわけですよね
だから最初に間で最初の間にはですねそんなにたくさん話ししなくてもいいです
とりあえず聞いたり読んだりすればいいと
思うんですよ僕も今グリー者語を勉強してますけれども
何よりも合意を増やしてそのたくさん弾いて全般的な根来
を改善したいんですよどれほど今もう
4ヶ月5ヶ月ぐらいもブリーフを勉強してますけども
どれくらい今話できるかというのはそういうほど私にとっては大切ではないんですよ
それが第二階最初の家にですねそんなたくさん話ししなくてもいい
第3話ですね実際にこの話しかけるときにした端
話するときにですねじゃあどういう同様その回はどういう話が大切なのかというとそれ
が意味のあるその
本物
海は本物のコミュニケーションなんですよ
某国語の人といろんな場面でその会話をするのが
非常なわけなんですよなぁあの
学校でロールプレイをのヤンてやったりですねそういうような火自然的な
者の
まあ話というのは会話というかっていうかそれほど効果的じゃないんです
だから母国語でない人たちと意気な話をしてもですねそれは本物のその母国語の人と人
たちと一緒になってですねもう毎晩前歯
足を聞いたりしたりしてそれのほうがやはり
まあ必要なわけですね商標経験があの
ないと
非常23の流暢に話せるっていうのが非常に難しいです
それで今の第4電話ですね
大体のまあ日本で英語を勉強中
している方とかまあ他の国でもいろいろな外国語を勉強している方ですね人たちはです
ね
所有敵今説明した今経験はないわけですよ
そういう機会がないわけですだから
その自分が思うほど流暢に話せないということに対してはそれほど批判的になって
ほしくないんですよ自分が多分思ってる以上に上手くまず言葉使ってるわけで実際に
それからもう一つはですね
小
you
たくさんその実際のいマーションというかその国へてこういう経験
そういう機会がなかったらそんなに自由に話せるはずないんですよ
だからあまり濃い
事項に対してやんしない方がいいですよ自分の表現力に対してはですね
しかし逆にですねそれ次のて名前ですね
私の経験ではねそのよく行くんですよ
あのう
例えば日本でいやー私が英語はよく分かりますけれども
読みます読めますね
そして
きっ聴けるんですけれども話しできないと
だから逆に自分のその
言えばその理解力はねぇ
まあか上場化する場合もあるわけです
なぜかというともしそういう人に対してはねじゃあ私が質問するんですよ
ああそうですかじゃあ小説の井川が英語で
読むのが好きですかてきもー
たくさんも英語の小説読めました
そんなに読まないって言うんですよあるいはその英語あの映画なんか見るときに大体
もうほとんどわかりますか
あるいはオーディオ僕なんか聞いたらわかりますか
だいたい返事はいいやそれができないとっとなるとですね
そのまだまだこの上手に話せる
ためにですねやはり
理解力
読める能力いける聞いて曲がる
能力これをやはり連絡しないといけないんです
でもし小説ももう簡単に読めますと楽しく読めますとオーディオ僕も
聞いて分かりますとか映画見てみれば分かりますというぐらいの理解力があればもう
この話乗る話す同僚はすぐ上達するんですよ
すぐ上達しますそういう準備が必要なわけなんですよ
だからその
例えばその部に入ってですねまぁ例えば体ならからまで来て
いろんな人と会っていろんなその立場いろんなその
海は森するようなねそういう機会を利用するためにですね準備しないといけない
じゃないとうまく利用できない可能性もあります
私のしてるまぁ意味の方だとかあるいはその生徒さんだでライブ劇で英語を勉強しよう
するような人たちですね
その
数錠がない意識宿雨すぎるんですよね
準備が足らないということで
この半年なら半年のからでの滞在はね
十分に利用できないっていう客観になってしまうんですよ
だからその準備するためにはですねやはり
まずインプの4なアクティビティというを
続かないといけないんですねそしてその t ても
そして読んでもですねこれはエクスペンシブなね
いわゆる広範囲のいえばその他同2丁と
そしてインテンスイブな集中的なその
たーーーードクター長と両方が必要なわけですよ
で
僕の場合は80%がそういう広範囲な新しい
面白い
弊社の
材料むしろ内容読んだり
その合意を増やしたり
調整するんでしょだけども2%はですね
比較的簡単なものを繰り返して繰り返して聴いたり読んだりショル
だからこちら9第8話ですね自分のいわゆる利用できるような単語やフレーズに
なってほしいわけでしょだから
繰り返して読んだり繰り返して聴いたりするわけですよ
それがまあ15は殴らないし20%が80%はやはり新しいものを
冒険するというか新しいものを選んでうん
合意を増やしていくとその両方が必要なわけなんですよ
そしてもう一つその本当のそのまあその国にイプ
前にその準備という意味ではですねもちろんその学校行ったり
ダークの中でロールから言えないし先生と話をしたりほかの生徒たちと話をしたり
それが ios カイポ通じて話をする
スカイプを通じて話をする場合はですね
やはりそのミスした単語やフレーズですね
先生に頼んで層が大挙いつもそう押しますけれどもそれをリストもらってそれをまあ
勉強します
場合によってその先生がその
も単語たプレイですね録音しますよねそれはなしへ
おりますと私それを勉強しましたもう一つはですね
もう書くことですねやはり書くその策謀ずる時にですね
もう時間があるから考えて場合によって google を使ってその文法の9点5
ですね調べたり
あるいは動くタンスレイプでも使ってですね
時間をかけても書くわけでしょ潮流もやはり
話の一つの順番にも知恵リョービにもなります
しかし結果的にますね最終的にその本当に流暢に上手に話せるためにやはりその口に
入ったりあるいはそういう
ネイティブの人達に囲まれた
有用なその環境を作らないと
やはり
に話す鼻栓そのリズ長の度合いがですね
やはり言動があると思います
まあそういうようなことで
ぜひ
まあ
これがまあ散歩れ
なったら非常に今幸いだと思います
通りだとさようなら
[音楽]
ん
バーバパパ